project veritas has released documents
corroborating earlier reporting and
providing new information an assessment
from a major previously of darpa
making a lot of very serious and bold
claims based on his analysis of
undisclosed documents and i have to tell
you
this may be one of the most important
stories of
man i don't even know the past decade
the past two decades because if this
assessment is correct it's confirmed a
lot of what the quote unquote conspiracy
theorists have said and i will also
point out that it'll basically get a
well i'll be very careful about how i
phrase things but uh youtube might not
be too happy with what the assessment is
so we will be careful and i'll try to be
as responsible as possible in the
assessment of this information but it's
huge this is information proving dr
fauci lied well assuming one of these
documents is correct fauci did lie
assuming the documents that were
previously released by the intercept
shows
fauci did lie
and then he appeared in front of
congress again today and made one of the
most hilarious mistakes of holding up a
piece of paper on tv which is now on the
internet and uh this is going to be
crazy stuff so we got that talk about
fauci was caught on a hot mic
apparently insulting one of the senators
we've got another crazy story the us
army is going to be conducting drills
training special forces in overthrowing
illegitimate governments and quote
unquote freedom fighters this comes
around the same time the doj is
establishing a counter-domestic terror
unit and the financial times says it's
time to implement psychological
operations against those who spread
misinformation
we got supply chain issues store shelves
are empty so this is going to be pretty
interesting we definitely got to talk
about this disinformation stuff we've
got someone who can speak to us in terms
of what's going on in the censorship
battle and infrastructure battle we've
got the ceo of rumble chris pavlovski
how's it going man great thank i'm super
excited to be here i've been watching
you for a long time so it's uh
appreciate you coming you know we've
we've been um
you know ian and i have well ian's been
more critical than i have been but we've
also been a little defensive too of of
you guys over at rumble especially with
like the locals deal so this will be a
really great conversation to talk about
your mission
uh the deal you know you just did this
um
you're doing the special uh purpose
acquisition company gonna raise a lot of
money i think there's a lot of good news
to be said here a lot of concerns but
we're getting all that stuff uh do you
wanna just quickly introduce like who
you are i know i said you're the ceo of
rumble but yeah i know sure i'm chris
pavloski i'm the founder and uh chief
executive
executive officer of rumble i started
the company in 2013 i've been in this
space for for two decades so
um i've seen a lot of stuff in the last
eight years if anyone were to look at
and see what our politics were in 2013
it was cats and dogs and then
by 2020 uh everything kind of changed
and uh we had congressman devin nunes
join our platform
um now rand paul right yeah rand paul
just dropped he dropped youtube last
week to come to rumble so uh we we had
the best week we've ever had last week
this is this all comes together full
circle too so it's good that we have you
here considering what's going on with
rand paul once again talking to fauci
because rand paul has tried to speak on
the senate floor and youtube banned this
content this is crazy stuff so we'll
we'll get in all that we got luke
hanging out this should be a great
conversation thank you so much for
coming here and i think it's fair to say
that the official story is definitely
breaking and people are realizing that
you cannot comply your way out of
tyranny just an important message that i
wanted to remind everyone and if you
want to remind your local karen's and
kyle's out there at the local
supermarkets of that same message you
can very easily by getting the shirt
that says you know you cannot comply
your way out of tyranny which you could
get on the best
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do i'm here thanks for having me this
should be a great conversation oh yeah
uh hey ian crossland here from ian
crossland.net and chris i'm glad you're
here i you know i worked with mines for
about a decade uh co-founded the company
and basically running ethics i'm the
ethics guy bill asked me to come in and
help him
guide the the process so i feel like i
know i can empathize with a lot of what
you're experiencing i saw bill go
through it and i'm excited to hear about
what it was like to go uh public and and
the code talk about already talked about
freeing the code base and yeah we'll go
deeper so it's great to see you thank
you well well i'd love to hear your
thoughts on that because i argue with
him all the time but uh we also got
lydia pressing all the buttons i am here
in the corner pushing buttons i upload
all the videos from irl to rumble as
well so i had a question that i already
cleared up with him it was great he's
going to be a great conversation this
evening before we get started everybody
head over to timcast.com become a member
to help support our fierce and
independent journalism we have a very
large team of reporters and i gotta be
honest with you guys it's not cheap to
hire journalists journalists are
specialists with special skills that
dedicate a lot of time and energy they
never take time off they're making phone
calls all day you got we got some of
these people that wake up at two in the
morning with breaking news they got to
get to work you guys all of you signing
up as members at timcast.com allow these
people to keep doing this work and we
take it very seriously we're also going
to be implementing our fact-checking
organization ramping it up very very
soon and that will also be to a certain
degree um funded through you guys
memberships but it's going to have its
own independent process for doing it but
uh we got it we're going to try and make
sure we keep them as separate entities
so that's important to to uh mention and
we'll get into more detail on how that's
going to work
in the next coming weeks and months but
you will also get access to exclusive
members only segments of the timcast irl
podcast as a member and we will have
that members only segment up tonight
around 11 or so p.m 11 p.m at
timcast.com so so go sign up but don't
forget to like this video smash that
like hand it's a hand
smack it and subscribe to the channel uh
share the show with your friends it's
the most powerful thing you can do to to
help combat to help combat the
misinformation
of the mainstream corporate press
and uh let's read this first big story
from project veritas i can already i can
already hear
the the clacking knees of the youtube
uh ban agents or moderators with their
fingers over the band button shaking
saying say the wrong thing we're gonna
ban your show
because we're about to talk about
something big project veritas reports
military documents about gain of
function contradict fouchy testimony
under oath military documents state that
eco health alliance approached darpa in
march 2018 seeking funding to conduct
gain of function research of bat born
coronaviruses the proposal named project
defuse was rejected by darpa over safety
concerns and the notion that it violates
the gain of function research moratorium
the main report regarding the eco-health
alliance proposal leaked on the internet
a couple months ago
it has remained unverified until now
project veritas has obtained a separate
report to the inspector general of the
department of defense written by u.s
marine corps major joseph murphy a
former darpa fellow
the proposal does not mention or assess
potential risks of gain of function
research a direct quote from the darpa
rejection letter project veritas reached
out to darpa for comment regarding the
the hidden documents and spoke with the
chief of communications jared adams who
said quote it doesn't sound normal to me
when asked about the way the documents
were buried
now i want to say a few things before we
get started
very simply
consult your doctor and don't take any
of this as medical advice we're not here
to provide that and take it all with a
grain of salt i've seen a lot of people
jump on this and and say i see two
things one the left saying
you can't trust project veritas their
information is no good and that
therefore it's bad i see people on the
right saying this is definitive proof
it's finally what we're looking for let
me just state
this reporting by veritas very well done
very very well done veritas didn't just
come out and release a letter from an
arm from a marine corps major assessing
certain information and then claim and
then trying to claim it's true they
actually got corroborating evidence of a
of an intercept story this is from
september 23rd 2021 leaked grant
proposal details high-risk chronovirus
research where they specifically mention
project diffuse
which project veritas has now
corroborated this this is a left-wing
publication and project veritas getting
documents on the same thing suffice it
to say the left's assessment of project
franchise being wrong is untrue that
being said
the the assessment from the major uh the
us marine corps major is just that it is
his analysis of undisclosed documents
trust them if you want to trust them or
don't i think it's very important to to
make sure that
you take into consideration it's not
someone involved in the projects
admitting to anything it's someone who
had been at darpa saying i read these
documents and here's my analysis that
being said i don't know luke if you want
to start bringing up some of these
points that you thought were most
alarming yeah i mean if these documents
are true i mean there's a lot of big
implications here because this shows how
echo health alliance was seeking darpa
funding in specific gain of function
research related to bat coronaviruses
they called this project diffuse and
allegedly according to these documents
this was rejected by darpa in 2018
because of safety concerns and it would
violate a lot of of course
the protections that are in the united
states that don't allow this kind of
dangerous work which could lead to some
very serious ramifications what did niid
do what the echo health alliance do
after this they just simply said well
there's no regulations and safety
concerns in china where the chinese
government gets to do whatever they want
as long as they oversee every step of
the process and essentially i think it's
fair to assume now that they took this
very dangerous work which allegedly
according to these documents darpa
didn't want to do because it was too
dangerous it was too unsafe and just
they just did it in china
which proved that there was some warning
some hindsight here that that should be
of course known about that should be
talked about there was also u.s senator
rand paul questioning
dr faucia about a lot of this there's
also the the gop oversight committee
releasing the emails and the
communications with niad specifically
showing how dr fauci is being accused of
concealing about a lot of the origin of
this story coming from that wuhan
laboratory with where this dangerous
function studies were being sent to and
downplaying this lab leak theory
that's big we had uh it was peter
navarro who was on the show and he said
that
at the time they were having these
meetings about covid and this potential
pandemic fauci was there and did not
disclose to them the things he had known
about gain of function about eco health
alliance and even if they didn't believe
the lab leak theory or hypothesis or
whatever don't you think fauci should
have told the trump administration hey
there's something we considered and it's
this that it may have come from this lab
you would you would think that if that
administrative state answered to the
executive branch which apparently i'm
learning in my adult years that it
doesn't necessarily uh it doesn't
necessarily play
second fiddle to the the executive
branch what i'm saying is the
administrative
state the deep these people that have
been there for 40 years fauci been in
that job for 40 years
he doesn't answer to joe biden highest
paid government employee right yep and
then 132 000 is that a salary
yup that's that's a huge amount of money
i got actually for a government worker i
got i got to read a portion of this
analysis because i'm not going to look i
understand that um this can be
considered contentious so i'm going to
read this portion from the defense
advanced research projects agency
document from commandant of the marine
corps fellow at darpa to the inspector
general subject sars kovi ii origins
investigation with the u.s government
program
undisclosed document analysis that right
there is very important to consider
this is somebody who worked at darpa who
read the following documents and is
providing his analysis
but his analysis is absolutely insane
okay and and you can take that any
direction you want someone on the left
is going to be like this dude's out of
his mind and people on the right be like
yo this is crazy in the more colloquial
sense
he says
you ready for this
sars cov2
is an american-created recombinant bat
vaccine or its precursor virus it was
created by an eco-health alliance
program at the wuhan institute of
virology as suggested by the reporting
surrounding the lab leak hypothesis the
details of this program have been
concealed since the pandemic began these
details can be found in the ecohealth
alliance proposal response to the darpa
pre-empt program broad agency
announcement dated march 2018 a document
not yet publicly disclosed the contents
of the proposed program are extremely
detailed
peter dashik lays out step by step what
the organization intends to do by phase
and by location the primary scientists
involved their roles and their
institutions are indicated the funding
plan for the wiv work is its own
document the reasons why
non-pharmaceutical interventions like
masks and medical countermeasures like
mrna vaccines do not work well can be
extrapolated from the details
the reasons why the early treatment
protocols work as curatives are apparent
now that is where
you start to get into danger zone
territory but let me just i want to make
sure it's very clear
this is this is a major at darpa giving
his assessment of these documents now
this is an expert i mean this is a guy
who's privy to information that was not
publicly disclosed talking about what he
thinks about it that being said
take it with a grain of salt you've got
to decide for you what you think is is
uh you know what what's trustworthy and
what's not and i will very much add as
it pertains to what he's saying that is
the opinion of this major not the show
it is not medical advice and always
consult a trusted medical professional
on your medical decisions and and what
needs to happen for you and i'll just
keep it you know i'll leave it there
yeah i mean this is his assessment after
looking at some of the classified
information that the public is not privy
to i think right now the conversation
has been started and for the government
to clear everything up here to have some
transparency and accountability they
should release these documents
immediately so they could set the record
straight specifically so we know exactly
what's going on here you want us to
trust us give us reason to give us these
documents release them the time is now
more than ever to do so i'm weary a
little bit i'm wary you know i don't
think i i think uh project veritas has
released the other defused documents
which is corroborating reporting we got
a few months ago and i think that was
smart it shows that these additional
documents they receive do come from a
verified source
however many people have pointed out
doesn't this seem a little too good to
be true like too on the nose a better
way to play uh maybe but also it's kind
of like the emperor is not wearing any
clothes you guys
uh duh we've thought this maybe that
there was a lab leak going on for like i
don't know eight months it's starting to
be well more accepted or five months or
six months well now it's like
uh okay just don't ban me for pointing
out that the emperor has no clothes for
a second but this this could be a psy
but we're going to talk about that in
just a little bit no no for sure it
might be invisible clothes yeah this
could be uh a psyop perhaps we know that
there were attempts to uh provide false
documents to wikileaks in the past
tricking them into publishing them so
they could then say aha look wikileaks
publishes false information
but i also want to point out could it be
that this major
read the same news sources or watch
tucker carlson and then wrote a report
based on what he saw in the news it
could be fabricated yeah not fabricated
just like you know he says um what does
he say uh he actually mentions in in the
article as reported you know
oh
the lab leak hypothesis as reported or
whatever he says right so you think it
might be partisan like political they're
trying to not necessarily political but
you know his view you know it it's it's
tough out of sight out of mind and and
the opposite right if people
don't hear something in the news they
don't talk about it if people do hear
the news they talk about it i'm just
saying it's possible that this guy may
have just it may sound like a bit on the
nose because maybe he's getting for all
we know this guy watches this show
and then he's like wow that's crazy then
he writes a report he reads the document
says yep i see it and then we then end
up reading it being like ah and it's
just confirming you know what we what we
already believed well i'm inside i agree
with you on the timing of this this does
seem a little bit suspicious to me
because all of this all of these jake
tapper is starting to agree with these
crazy right-wing conspiracies they're
admitting that like the menstrual
changes that women were reporting that
they said was nonsense all this is
happening at the same time very
convenient yeah so that's a good point
we've got
npr
saying yes actually the vaccines do
alter your menstrual cycle something
women had been saying for the past
couple of years that was deemed a
conspiracy theory then you get jake
tapper outraged that covet
hospitalizations are inflated by some 40
percent then we get this document
basically giving giving an expert
confirmation or an expert analysis which
lends itself to lab leak hypothesis that
does smell like a psy up to me they were
actually i don't want to outright say
it's discredited numbers would have been
inflated by 60
if 40 of them were
of the total had been inflated that
means when you have 60 is your full
amount to get to 100 you're gonna have
to increase it by 40 which is 60 of 60
they're about so it's actually inflating
the number by it's it's a little not
necessarily kind of a derailment but
they inflated the numbers by 60 percent
to get to a place where it says that 40
of them
uh didn't had had co-morbidities and
well so they've basically
no no the inflation was when they said
that people with kovid
instead of from kovitz yeah that was new
york state announcing that with the
governor officially saying there was a
really funny tweet i retweeted someone
said is is american democracy dying with
covet or from coven and i was like
that's actually that was a really really
good one yeah but uh yeah in this
instance with with jake tapper the issue
is someone bumps their head goes to the
hospital
they say we're going to test you for
covid
when when i had kovid and i called the
local hospital i was like what's the
protocol like what should i do they said
why don't you come in and i said okay
well what do i do if i come in they said
we'll run some tests and i said why
would i need tests done like i took an
at-home test it said i had kovit and
they were like well we'll come in and
we'll do some tests and then i i kid you
not that's and i said and then what do
you do for me are you gonna prescribe
medicine i said no and i said so i
should just like leave my home and come
here so you can tell me what i already
know
should i i was like i was calling
because i was wondering if there was
like a if there was something you can do
or if there's something i should do and
they're like oh no it's a virus go to
sleep and uh okay
but they wanted me i i swear so
afterwards i was like they want me to
just come in for tests is it because
they're they want to just run billing
paid baby we were talking about that
yesterday how much money these these
organizations are getting for having a
coveted case having a cove of death on
file on ventilator putting people on
ventilators and that's just on file with
covet on file and that it's treated as
as it was a covid let's pull up this uh
this tweet here we got from the
oversight committee republicans breaking
we've released never before seen emails
showing dr fauci may have concealed
information about covid19 originating
from the wuhan lab and intentionally
downplayed the lab leak theory i gotta
say all of this coming out at the same
time is kind of insane it's after
christmas everyone's fed up my family
was done with it over christmas they
could be burning fouchy uh fauci is
again sort of a conduit and a middle
player to a lot of other bigger players
and and also has a lot of communications
with other individuals that are named to
mr gates but that's a whole different
story to say itself but i think the
question is is this acai up is an
important one especially when we're
having so much information come out i
think we're at a very important turning
point i think a lot of things are going
to change within the next month within
the next two months i think it's
important to look out and i think this
could be also an attempt to uh release a
lot of this information to save their
buttocks uh family-friendly show here
to
to sustain to kind of uh soften their
fall from the the grace of of covet
overlords many people have pointed out
the democrats aren't going to win if
they're running on covet lockdowns yeah
the polling is not going to be in their
favor right now everything's turning
like you know in canada where i'm from
is you can see it people are so fed up
like there has to be a turn here and i
think that's what we're seeing maybe
this gives the democratic uh party and
the establishment an out jake tapper oh
oh i can't believe that these numbers
can you believe it oh i'm on your side
i'm angry too and then all of a sudden
democrats are like we know fauci let us
down vote for us yeah i saw a tweet
today i was this lady was like all the
lies are coming out you know
everything's being revealed and i was
like no lady these democrats have a 2022
midterm to drag out they need to fix
this now and they're just now realizing
they're a little bit slow but they're
they're on the case now so so this this
document release from uh the the
oversight committee
uh let me let me read a little bit for
you they say we write to requ request a
transcribed interview of dr anthony
fauci director u.s national
we get it um
enclosed reveal that dr fauci warned of
two things the potential that covet 19
leaked from the wuhan institute of
virology and 2 the possibility that the
virus was intentionally genetically
manipulated it is imperative we
investigate if this information was
conveyed to the rest of the government
and whether the information would have
changed the u.s response to the pandemic
so fauci had apparently excerpts they
say excerpts of emails we are making
public today reveal uh reveal that
information uh fauci as we as we uh um
we learned with fouchy leaks remember
that
anthony fauci was communicating with
several individuals and they were
questioning whether or not this did come
from a land that's why i mentioned peter
navarro
he had stated that when he was in the
trump administration and they had fauci
there and they're like what's going on
fauci did not tell them
that they believed it was possible that
the lab leak happened i think at this
point we may not have an official from
the wuhan lab because you never will
because it's china coming out and
definitively saying yes it happened but
i think when jon stewart rants on
colbert's show that there's no other
reasonable explanation
then we're already at that point right
it is it is likely a lab leak now here's
what it's fascinating when rand paul
said that fauci was responsible for this
and then he said i have no
responsibility for this and it's it's
just crazy because who are they still
trying to convince
right at this point
most i think yes most people will be
like yeah i probably came from that lab
jon stewart said it right they're
probably trying to convince the people
that own fouchy bobbleheads
yeah that's a that's a that's a good way
to describe them
what do you call those kind of
individuals i don't know bobbleheads
that's another that's another reason but
but you know
there's a lot of information coming
forward right now why did you think
about those first things
that's actually a really good way to
identify like i almost got you one dude
i'm gonna get you really yeah no like
you can actually buy dr fauci
bobbleheads the kind of person who has
this yes or like those candles those
votive candles oh yeah where it was like
st oh geez
oh my gosh
he'd be a great guest i don't know if
he'd actually say anything if he'd just
be defensive he could even get him or he
wouldn't i think from today's hearings
especially with us senator rand paul
it's pretty clear that fauci is not used
to being asked any tough questions he
was hammered by rand paul i believe
correctly so on on very important issues
on a lot of these emails on a lot of
these documents and dr fauci's response
was it's not true there's people that
don't like me and threaten me i mean
does he know he's talking to rand paul
who literally was attacked by his
neighbor who was literally shot at like
that was his argument that's not an
argument dr fauci lay out your argument
present the data present your
information and be able to reach across
the aisle and talk to the other side he
has never done that he only does
softball interviews where the pundits
literally
family friendly show
do adult things to him with their uh
mouth
all right all right that's too much
i'm not i'm not going there well but
it didn't uh i didn't see it but you
mentioned crowder yeah
yeah so right at the end of his like
publicly available show he mentioned
that we've been swatted more than fouchy
has like tim pool's been swatted more
than you have complaining i appreciate
the shout out
i think it's pretty clear when dr fauci
is on the corporate media which he loves
to be on he always gets gets softball
question he always gets massage he
always gets fauci why are you so great
and awesome and and super incredible and
helping save the world that's literally
the type of questions that he can ask
they answer questions for him too
they'll say things like i was curious
your position on the virus because a
bunch of right wing channels were lying
by saying x y and z and of course we
know a b and c so
uh would you like to reiterate what i
just said dr fauci yes that's absolutely
correct the droplets and the masks
exactly and i i think today's hearings
prove that there wasn't any kind of real
discussion it was very testy and i think
it's pretty clear from everyone watching
that dr fauci doesn't have an argument
here and he's definitely on the wrong
side of the larger debate that's
unfolding right now with what a lot of
people are thinking and we're afraid to
express but now it's finally coming out
to the limelight as of course everything
that's being exposed right now the
supposed conspiracy theorists we're
literally saying from the very beginning
of this they were censored on big tech
social media they were denied having a
voice in this conversation and now those
conspiracy theorists were really just
spoiler alerts as of course everything's
coming true so in my 1pm segment i
opened with a princess bride reference i
love that it actually it actually was
hard for me to get right i had to try
recording like 10 times
i opened with fauci fell victim to one
of the classic blunders the most famous
of which is never get involved in a land
war in asia and only slightly i see
that's a good one slightly less
well-known is never hold up a piece of
paper on television because you will
become a meme amazing you see i couldn't
even do it right now after all that
practice
but that's that's actually one of the
funniest takeaways from this from that
moment fauci actually picked up a piece
of paper which i will not do and it said
it it's a picture of him and it says
fire fauci and he's pointing at it
angrily and i'm like yes
yes we agree
thank you for this for this um pantomime
of what we all should do but it was
funny too because it was rand paul's
website
which is fundraising and he was like it
says fire fouchy and you can give one
dollar two dollars
five i'm like this is a great pitch
like he's advertising for it so i i
don't know the whole thing was just
ridiculous but what i love about fauci's
responses to rand paul
is the way i describe it is he's like
rand paul goes
dr fauci you were were engaging in gain
of function research at the wuhan
institute through funding equal health
alliance and voucher will be like no we
did not er the the example i give is
like fauci's explanate is rand paul says
you put a door in my bedroom in fact
it's not a door it's just a large piece
of wood on hinges with a knob that when
you turn moves a piece of metal which
allows you to open on the hinges and
enter the room and you're like bro
you're describing a door to me that's
how he does the gain of function it is
not gain the function research it is
just the creation of chimeric viruses to
increase transmissibility
you're describing gain of function dr
fauci no i'm not that's literally what
he did that's crazy you know i want i
think this guy should be arrested i'm
not even kidding absolutely uh
subpoenaed uh questioned thoroughly
release all the documents release all
the studies that he's done and when you
truly find out what he's been
responsible for there's no going back to
the official narrative that he has set
on the american people because you learn
about things like robert f kennedy jr in
his book the real anthony fauci talking
about how
people were horribly affected by his
studies whether it was orphans whether
it was monkeys whether it was beagle
puppies there's there's a long trail of
just horrible misdoings by this man and
i think it's more than time than ever
that we hold them responsible for all
those actions yeah i want to buy a
bobblehead oh yeah let's get a bunch of
them let's get different ones if we can
find them
because it's energy and inviting the
devil into the house but it's not
hilarious it is funny like you know we'd
have it for the opposite reason that
they would we gotta get kyrie irving
bobblehead too i mean that's kind of
cool yeah
yeah yeah they let him play again yeah
he's playing yeah i love that
signal man the money was more important
than the pandemic i guess they couldn't
have enough players because the test the
players that were vaccinated kept
getting coveted
and they had to bring in the
unvaccinated players and this is not
just happening with sports ball teams
this is happening in hospitals this is
happening in supermarkets there's even
official government notices saying hey
if you test positive just show up to
work anyway literally there's
supermarkets telling people to do this
because of the staff and labor shortages
in major institutions and and we're at a
point in this pandemic where the the
unvac can't get work the sick that are
testing positive are told to go back to
work that's absolutely crazy it's
actually very very normal because this
was only supposed to be 15 days to slow
the spread anyway that you're not
supposed to shut down the economy and
this is the economy like gasping for air
like we can't survive if we don't bring
in anyone that may or may not have it
doesn't matter at this point because our
survivability is more important it's
like when you said people were climbing
out of the bomb shelters even when the
bombs kept dropping like bro you got to
get back to life at some point yeah so
uh last night mike rowe uh pointed out
in the uk during what was the blitz
bombing of london the bombing of london
after a few days people were like okay
the bombs are still going off i guess
it's time to get back to work
because you couldn't just stay locked in
your basement you would just wither away
so even with what they're using
zeppelins right yeah the germans were
like they were using zeppelins for sure
for observation i don't know if they
were dropping bombs from zeppelin but
they were dropping bombs on london
people were like eh back to work and
bombs are going off stay calm carry on i
think we're at that point are they
getting rocketed i think we're at the
point where hospitals are just like okay
we can't function anymore just bring
back the nurses bring back the unvaxxed
nurses burn back kyrie irving bring back
thank god man that's the natural i mean
the natural flow of any of any disease
anyway of any epidemic is eventually get
back to it
let's talk about psychological
operations my friends we got this story
from the financial times
psyops are a crucial weapon in the war
against disinformation well this is
clearly fake news because mass formation
psychosis isn't real oh yeah it's not
it's not real that ap told me so reuters
said it's not real for those that watch
joe rogan's podcast you need not hear me
explain this but for those that missed
it dr robert malone brought up how in
you know the early 1900s or you know 30s
people were trying to understand how it
is that these authoritarian regimes took
power namely nazi germany
and he mentioned something called mass
formation psychosis where people were
all basically fixated on something they
were hypnotized all of a sudden the
media comes out claiming it's not true
google changes the search results so
you're not finding it and now
it's it's funny because you had many
many stories over the past several years
from mainstream and corporate
publications saying that trump was
hypnotizing people
but when when you know even from the ap
the ap said that even from the ap
and so now you have for the financial
times psychological operations are a
crucial weapon in the war against
disinformation but far be it from any
from from us to claim that there's
manipulation and hypnosis and propaganda
you know what the craziest thing to me
is when i would explain to people uh
there's a field of the of hacking
agriculture called social engineering
the overwhelming majority of hacking
that you hear in the news is actually
just social engineering someone's not
typing away code and there's like you
know smiling laughing faces appearing on
the screen eating the numbers like
ridiculous graphics hacking is almost
always some guy picking up a phone
calling the the bank and being like hi
i'm john i'm a branch manager it's you
know bank number 3942 i'm looking for
your irs you know a verification number
and just tricking people that's what
hacking tends to be
this when i try to explain to people
this they always just say oh that would
never work on me
never work if it wouldn't then why does
it exist if you can't be manipulated why
does coke spend so much money buying
advertisements so when they come out and
say mass formation psychosis of course
it's a real thing
of course people are trying to
manipulate you every day now the
financial times is advocating for
psychological operations over coveted
misinformation which brings me to what
we have to deal with the censorship
which is a prime component of this
making sure people can't share ideas
sometimes the ideas are so dangerous
they'll shut off a live stream
mid-stream they'll ban a channel
outright with no strikes because the
information can't be allowed well
sometimes it's not even that they're
dangerous it's just that they're
misinterpreted which is a problem that
there's a human that's capable of
misinterpreting a message and then
banning it but this is different this is
army psychological operations literally
using the power of information denying
information lying about information
making up information in order to have
political games this is psychological
warfare against the american people that
the financial times is calling to be
instituted here in the united states and
they use sweden as the perfect example
because in sweden they have the swedish
psychological defense agency that
couldn't be more of an orbaly name than
it could be but they are out there not
only to monitor what's happening online
not just the political discussions but
they also are there to launch
counter-attacks against their believed
falsehoods about vaccines immigration
and other very important issues so they
also talked about in this article how
they they use this psychological
operation to deal with political
tensions in europe so so this is an
important distinction to understand here
financial times is saying sweden's doing
this we need to do this here we already
do this here in the united states a lot
of this is classified and i think a lot
of this is very evident when you see the
same kind of regurgitated talking points
the same kind of narrative and anything
questioning getting outright censored
and banned there's also of course people
planting fake stories and fake
disinformation in order to throw people
off the original trail there's a lot of
things happening here and i think once
you institute psychological tricks by
the us army to to push an agenda that
only clearly benefited the billionaire
class the billionaires are making more
money than ever this is something that
is absolutely concerning this is
something that is absolutely worrying
and this is something that we need to
realize is happening here in the united
states on a huge level already this is
what we see with the banning of the
hunter biden laptop story on twitter and
facebook and so uh sitting before us we
got uh we got two people well we got the
ceo of rumble and you guys are
is it fair to say your anti-censorship
on rumble absolutely um we're
what you're what you're seeing right now
but you gotta you have to explain that
anti-censorship yeah you ban content
don't you well absolutely yeah we do and
uh we have policies that have been in
place since 2013
and we haven't really we haven't moved
the goal post since that time um
obviously
you know terrorist organizations
promoting terrorist organizations
incitement to violence child pornography
pornography all that stuff's not
acceptable on the platform
and uh but what's what we're seeing here
right now and kind of why you've seen
companies like rumble grow is
not because of the terms and conditions
that we put together in 2013 that really
has no effect on on what has happened
um what you're seeing is that these
companies these
whether it's google or whether it's
twitter are now becoming arbiters of
truth they're they're being asked or
they're being forced or they're being
demanded by whether it's journalists or
governments to
basically determine what's
what's good and what's not good imagine
me
how irresponsible would it be for me to
be the person that's going to tell you
what you can or cannot say
i went to university i dropped out in
third year and you want me to be that
person that's that's irresponsible you
want this the the ceo of youtube to be
that person that determines what is
right and what is wrong well they're
scared of losing advertisers i think is
a big component i do think that there is
absolutely a national defense component
we've heard tons of stories about
you know a federal agencies going to
tech firms and saying
you have to do what we tell you and if
you tell anyone we told you to do this
we will destroy you yeah gag orders yeah
someone asked me to kind of ask you will
rumber rumble volunteer information
about its users to regulators in law
enforcement or will you guys demand a
warrant that's one of the questions that
someone
was was really interested if you could
answer
yeah we're not going to just hand over
information we're you know it's got to
go through the proper channels it has to
be legally done and uh if you know
there's a subpoena we'll
we'll follow the law in in all cases we
have to follow the law that's that's our
that's our duty at mines we have a weird
position well interesting it was a if
it's legal in the united states then
it's legal fine on mines it's part of
the terms and that meant like state law
like what state were we incorporated in
i think the time was connecticut so it's
connecticut state law but then you'd get
these things like lolly porn which is
like cartoon porn and the people look
young and they look under 18 but it's
cartoons so there's no human there's no
it's not illegal but it's devastating to
smear a website with that stuff so
you're like well
we have to do something about this and
so there's this clause you can ban
anything at any time i mean pretty much
any network can ban anybody at any time
yeah when you when we started websites
like 20 years ago like that's like a
standard term that every lawyer will put
in so it makes things easy and you know
that that's one of the problems right is
that when we started rumble we we have
these sets of terms and conditions that
were just so standard on the internet
everybody had pretty much the same terms
and conditions but
you know that's where everybody wants us
to have that conversation they want us
to have the conversation around the
really fringy stuff and all that stuff
but that's not what's happening here
that's not why companies like rumble are
growing rumble is growing because
something
more overt and egregious is happening
and that's because you can't even have a
conversation that you have at your
dinner table anymore um an open
conversation on on the internet think
about this think about what we're doing
right now on youtube we we can't have an
open conversation here there's a lot of
things we cannot talk about that if
these mics are off you could talk about
that we will at timcast.com in the
members only segment
and that's the craziest thing that we
have to do that uh and interestingly on
itunes and spotify and other platforms
they're actually much more lacked
spotify is actually fairly strict uh
because they've got internal people who
will ban you and there's no appeal
process worse than youtube but itunes
just goes hey look we don't host any of
the content we're just linking to it
yeah i think that's google podcast's
position as well i believe and if
someone violates the law this the state
should get involved here not of course
the arbiters of truths a middle person
that's going to say well this idea is
bad for you that that whole concept is
is patronizing and it's very
disrespectful to anyone paying attention
in my opinion there's like uh situations
where the law is bad and you want to
you know not not necessarily well look
nazi germany for instance we're just
talking about like death threats and the
free speech laws that we have on the
books if for instance a law got passed
that was so insidious and we're like
well we have to violate that law because
that's corrupt we can't absolutely that
it's hard to make a social network the
one that's like we're going to uphold
that and let people do when we're going
to let people violate the law because
then it's easy to find out where they
live you know who owns that site you
know where that data is hosted i i'm
very nervous about centralization of
authority um
holding data on a centralized network of
any kind whether it's email addresses um
search history because the nsa can just
go take it well let me let me ask the
more data the worse right you guys
yeah maybe there's a diminishing return
on that but yeah you guys are based in
canada
we are that's not good not good
especially with the legislation that
might come down in the next couple years
it it definitely is is not helpful at
this point in time but uh well so there
i mean you've got hate speech laws in
canada right that's right if the
government of canada came to you and
said you are hosting illegal content you
must take it down would you guys take it
down if it was illegal absolutely but
illegal in canada absolutely i'm not
going to jail so this so this means that
like
misgendering i think that's one of the
laws so one one of the things that we uh
that we're doing is that we're
headquartering down in sarasota florida
we announced that a couple months ago
that's a that's a big move that that
we're going to be doing as a company and
uh super excited to to go to florida
better weather too so
i actually would prefer the canadian
weather over florida to be honest really
absolutely yup well if you're a
snowboarder or skier then yeah i can
understand always i can always put on
more clothes i can i can't take all of
it you can never put on enough beanies
that's right sweat sweating is good for
you gets rid of a lot of waste and it is
stuff in your body it is but uh
you know florida's good in january
february i lived there for a year it was
brutal nobody goes outside but in canada
you know you've got some months and
you've got long winters where you just
you know make snowmen but but i i
digress the important question here is
there are a lot of people signing up on
rumble right now you know we're talking
about psychological operations we're
talking about whether companies are
willing to break the law obviously you
know luke is saying you if it's if it's
legal content it should be allowed but
where you're at right now in canada
i mean
have you been forced to ban anybody on
hate speech or anything like that by the
government or any
no institutions come to us uh with
respect to that uh
but i can tell you that
you know where
the legislation that is gonna come
that's that i think is even more
concerning is uh bill c-10 in canada
where the they want to have the
government actually regulate what kind
of content you are displaying and uh
through the crtc and think about that
they're going to control what you see
now um and whatever that may look like
it's in full progress if that passes and
then there's other legislation that's
being proposed now
um we haven't seen it but that could
happen in the next year as this uh the
trudeau government is continuing so
you know
the best thing for for rumble is just at
this point is to is to be prepared for
that situation and you know we'll we'll
be in florida and by this year so if i
could just ask you on a follow-up
question
if you're in canada right now the
canadian government says take this
content down you will but if you move
down to florida right and you
incorporate there and the canadian
government says i want you to hide this
video from our viewers will you get rid
of those videos when you're not in their
jurisdiction so jurisdictional issues is
a whole different thing because you have
the uk that has one set of laws you have
canada that has another set of laws you
have the u.s that has their set of laws
and we have to find a way to to meet the
laws of of every country and this this
gets so complicated when you think about
it like as a startup imagine a startup
having to like
have lawyers help you in every single
jurisdiction and fall it makes it so
difficult the barrier of entry just to
enter this market
is is so difficult to be to be like
youtube into competing against youtube
you need like significant financing
significant legal help signific there's
a lot to navigate it's so complicated um
and it makes it so hard but we're lucky
that we're in a really good place right
now where we have we have a pretty good
team and uh we're gonna we're gonna
follow each jurisdiction the way the way
it needs to be done so if canada says
get rid of this video and you're in
florida you will
it like i have to look at the situation
and the scenario i can't you know let's
just say someone misgendered someone on
on a rumble video the canadian
government says we want you to take that
down you're in florida what do you do so
at this point i i don't have an answer
for that because we haven't we haven't
come up with that
that policy we haven't looked at that um
and one of the things that we want to do
as we're growing like i said we've had a
policy since 2013 it's been virtually
the same in spirit um all the way
through the key for us is to never move
the goal posts like these other
companies every two weeks you're seeing
them change but we're also not
good enough because in 2013 it was one
it was one world and in 2000 i guess 22
now it's a whole different world so what
we want to do is uh you know after i did
the the podcast with aviva viva fray and
and robert barnes you know we had some
chats after that we we want to bring the
community in we want to bring guys like
robert barnes and viva frey to help us
develop this in a way that stays in the
spirit of free speech as much as
possible and really be able to handle
these jurisdictional issues that are
that are there these app store issues
that are there there we want to do it in
a way that
it's almost better if the community
helps us develop this than you know one
single authority like myself saying this
is how we're going to do and this is the
best way so what an app store we're
really we're
we're we're in talks to do that with
viva and robert barnes and uh
we you know i i want to bring in as many
people i want to you know seek your
advice too like how do you handle app
store issues and policy in terms of
conditions like these are such
tricky things
it's a cabal i mean let's be real the
this silicon valley operates like a
cabal when minds gets one tiny
infraction that's negligible they'll be
like we're going to knock you off the
app store whereas twitter just does
whatever they want i think i don't know
if that that is particularly poor was
that public that story yeah yeah porn
mines was often on the the app store
with dealing with porn issues whereas
twitter just had porn the whole time
allows it that's unbelievable when you
look at the double standard and that's
that's totally unfair how are we
supposed to compete as a company if
minds can't
you know get the same rule set that
twitter's getting the facebook first
thing you do is acknowledge it which we
just did and then you got to start
building a system where that is not part
of the system which is like a
decentralized
uh open free software meta-net i i agree
and you know decentralization is a huge
key but i think even before that right
now and this is one of the things that
we're really focused on is we got to
build we got to build infrastructure
because you can't turn anything on
without the infrastructure you saw what
happened to parlor they got turned off
overnight and then once you have the
infrastructure in place uh you know
common carrier-based infrastructure then
you can start building things and you
can you know you can really kind of take
all kinds of different businesses and
really build off of that if you want
people to help you build and if you want
to build a community you got to build a
lot of trust
so you know there's a big question you
guys got a lot of institutional money
that usually corrupts companies what
plan do you have to show that you won't
be corrupted and what can you offer the
people who are coming to you as as
transparency and oversight that you will
treat them differently than youtube did
yeah no this is a that's a great
question um
so one of the things that we did when we
decided to to merge with the with cfei
is we went out and raised money on the
premise that we're going to be immune to
cancer culture
we're we're going to be restoring the
internet to its roots by making it free
and open again building a cloud that's
going to be as close to a common carrier
as possible a rumble platform that is
not going to censor that's what we told
investors that's what we raised money on
that's what we're doing that's what we
went to cantor fitzgerald for
and
we now if we will be one of the first
companies to to enter the public markets
once this merge concludes
um
on the on that premise we're not on the
we're not going into the into the public
markets on the premise of a google that
requires you know
all these other things we're on the
premise that we're going to be immune to
cancel culture and if we don't live up
to that then we now have a massive
liability on our hands we have no choice
but to stick we put the stake in the
ground on that premise
twitter was the free speech wing of the
free speech party
yeah big money we need we need to bypass
fiat basically
well
twitter initially when they got started
they joked that they were the free
speech wing of the free speech party so
they made all the same statements and
promises youtube used to allow
uh the craziest videos pranks involving
violence and so i think it's really easy
for you to say like here's our mission
statement when you're growing and
competing but what happens when you
reach that that plateau where you're now
on a similar level and all of a sudden
you've got investors you've got
government interests you've got you know
you've got congress breathing down your
neck all of a sudden you're like it is
easier just to get rid of this and not
fight
yeah in in certain cases you might think
that um it all depends on the person
that's that's there um can you make
corporate bylaws
barring something i don't know that's a
good question i i don't know the answer
to that can we maybe make a pledge
towards transparency oversight well one
thing we did do um and i think this is
unprecedented is that
when after we announced the the merge
with cfei
um we we had a company ask us to
demonetize uh dan bongino
and instead of complying with doing that
gave him a raise
yes we did
we finally released the damn the clones
you respond to that we're giving him
what what we did is we canceled tremor
um unruly and tremor media uh they they
said we
you know they cited that uh they saw
content that they didn't like and we
asked them where's that content that
they don't like does that violate our
terms of service
no response
and and we said we said basically if you
don't provide us the information that
that uh that violates our term of
service we will
we're effectively canceling if you want
to appeal with us to get to bring ads
back on rumble uh you let us know by
this date so this is an advertisement
and we canceled we canceled one of the
largest uh advertising networks on the
planet um because they tried to cancel
dan bongino well that's canceled culture
now you're not just kidding
are you aware of the esg score
not not particularly i think that's
that's with respect to environmental so
this is the environmental social and
corporate government score that a lot of
bigger financial institutions like
blackstone use as a way of funneling
money into
of course big companies so to comply
with that you have to push a certain
narrative have certain beliefs have uh
certain amounts of people based on their
identities and their race and there's
there's many different things but but
they essentially the big money guys come
and say you guys got to play by these
rules you guys have a good score you
comply with our agenda you get more
money you get more loans what's
preventing you guys from being affected
by the esg score
well
and blackstone like if blackstone came
and said we'll give you a bunch of money
would you accept it
well they they i guess can't they just
publicly go and buy the the public
shares on the market isn't that how it
works they they have the option to do
that they know what we're all about if
they if they're supportive of our
mission and what we're doing and the
creators on our platform go ahead but
like at the same time
you know
we're we're not gonna i'm we're not
gonna bend our mission i'm not gonna
bend this mission i have roughly 85
voting control and i'm not going to bend
for changing this mission where the
mission is to restore the routes
to go to create that free and open
internet we once had what will happen is
uh blackstone like state street a big
investment firms will collude to get
like 20 percent of the company they
can't there's only 11 percent of roughly
11 available 11 percent available
and then canters are roughly two to
three it's all public this information
you're only selling 11 of the company
i'll have about 85 percent voting
control it's all public on on the site
you can kind of see the breakdown of the
of the current holders versus our
current holders are
a large portion of this i think how big
is your board
so i'm putting that together right now
um that's i'm working really hard is
that public even
it will it will become public that that
information that i would imagine that
these companies will try to get somebody
on your board and then once they're on
the board they start to see discontent
with other board members when you're not
around and that's how they'll try and
get you out but i'll have what they did
to doors i think i have 85 percent
control of voting shareholder voting
control so that that allows me to i i
think the rules
i don't want to speak out of line um but
i think the 85
allows a lot like you could just kick
somebody off the board
i don't it's yeah it's i don't know
hopefully i i don't know about canadian
law but this will be this will be u.s
this will be us in the united states you
still have to convene a meeting the
meeting has to be there's process
there's you have to abide by process and
you have to do everything by the book
and uh but when you have 85 percent uh
voting control to appoint boards of the
the directors uh that's a significant
controlling interest in the company
and uh it allows uh it it really really
allows us to protect that mission but i
also think that the bigger protection is
not just me having that that control
it's really drawing a stake in the sand
of what this company is our shareholder
base whoever is going to be buying
rumble is uh it really believes in what
we're doing i don't even i i'm not sure
if if institutions
will institutions be interested they
should be because it's going to i think
this is the future of the world i think
free freedom is you you can't buy that
that's something that you know we need
in this point on this planet more than
anything are you gonna are you ever
going to sell your stock um and and if
you do how much stock would you sell and
that's another question
how should i answer that one
um no so like
at this point
you know i'm all in and it what i'm
seeing on the
what i'm seeing on the internet and what
i'm seeing how this internet has changed
in the last 15 years um really
really it's really more of a mission now
than anything else in the in in the
world and i feel like we're
we're the tip of the spear of really
protecting the free and the open
internet especially if we really build
this infrastructure out and uh you know
we get we really support a lot of
businesses i i think that that's going
to be a really important really
important factor in in the next couple
years and i really need to go all in on
this this is not about selling out and
going out yeah the networking thing is
huge if we can somehow build a meshed
network maybe with devices like the
freedom phone or sort of phone where
people we can host our servers
i think you might be the guy to to leak
because i know your history in building
servers
and your interest in building up the
network i don't know
i'm sorry okay that's good i don't know
if i have uh enough faith in people you
know if uh
be it you or getter i think that for the
most part whether people want to
acknowledge it or not they're kind of
they're moving only in the direction
they can they can move in
so for a rumble for getter for uh even
minds
there's an opportunity in that youtube
is killing conversations you know
they they make it impossible to have
meaningful conversations it is harder
and harder every day and it's
fascinating when i see how many channels
will get a guideline strike over similar
conversations we'd have but obviously
we're a big show youtube's probably
scared because that's that's the way the
game is played that's the way the
machine works youtube can only do what
the culture will tolerate so what i mean
by that is
i fully believe like with what i saw at
vice there will come a point where
unless you put in legal
bylaws or restrictions or or something i
don't even know if that would work to be
honest
there it's only a matter of time before
rumble becomes youtube in the exact same
way but that doesn't mean right now what
you're doing is bad it means there's
always going to be a new market
opportunity for someone to bring back
real real and raw conversations yeah i
also think being private is more
dangerous in a sense um being public is
going to require us to be transparent
about what we're doing and you know when
you go out and raise money from
shareholders on a specific mission on
what you're going to do the second you
go against that mission you you have
liability so it's a different it's a
different standard when going public in
that i i don't know of any companies
that are trying to go public that are
saying that they're going to be immune
to cancer culture
what happens when you get
inundated with
uh
press we do and they say bad things
every day and it negatively impacts your
stock price
it doesn't but what's what happens in
five years let's put it this way in five
years you end up with an overt communist
you know on rumble who's building a big
following saying as close as he can
calling for insurrection a revolution
without crossing any legal lines and
then you end up with tons of people just
being like yo this is really bad
you know this guy is is purposefully
manipulating the platform he's doing all
these dirty things you need to get rid
of him and then all of a sudden all
these stories come out and everyone says
you guys you are you are allowing
something evil and wrong and then you
end up getting you know
negatively impacting your stock then the
shareholders revolt and say why won't
you get rid of this guy he's clearly
breaking the rules and then you ban him
right
we're going to ban someone that doesn't
violate our policy is not going to
happen if they're so so
perhaps and perhaps it's easy to say the
point i'm bringing up uh is like if he
doesn't violate our policies or
we're not banning doesn't your policy
say you can ban anybody at any time
i i don't i don't have that in front of
me i'm pretty sure it does most most
everybody does even if it does let's
let's say it does um
he's not violating any of our policies
we're not going to do that i'm not going
to do that that's not something i i i
can i can
hear what you're saying and perhaps
that's as far as we can go you say it
won't happen i say i believe at some
point it will i just feel like when you
open the door to any public investor for
any percentage
when you start getting
in you know shareholder revolt anger you
know saying you are not staying true to
your mission you're you'll have to abide
by what the the people in your company
the mission the mission is to keep it
free and open and
that that's the mission so what these
shareholders that are not interested in
that shouldn't be holding our stock they
shouldn't be part of that but they
should sell they should get out of it
because that's not what we're doing it's
it's not free and open to allow
communists to advocate for the complete
dissolution and destruction of the
united states if even if there's
incitement and violence that's a
different story but let's see what
they're organizing antifa rallies that
have resulted in violence
they've never explicitly said to do it
but they've said everybody should come
and come down here we're all black and
then all of a sudden mass violence keeps
breaking out i guess the question is are
they breaking our policy or not
if they're breaking the policy then
they're gone if they're not breaking the
policy then they're not going to and the
nsa is going to be all over that one
they'll be deep in your system watching
you might have an employee that works
for the nsa for all you know so how
would you do it how would what's the
best way to
to make sure
decentralize the data so that you don't
have control of it so that you can't ban
it only so here here's another what ian
said yeah that's that's a good that he's
right he's right in so many ways and one
of the things that we want to do and and
i've talked about this before
is imagine that every creator on rumble
you get access to your data
it's your data not ours imagine that
that's something from youtube for 20.
that's that's something let me let me
give you one let's say uh somebody here
here's your number one policy you may
not post or transmit any message which
is libelous defamatory or which
discloses private or personal matters
concerning any person or entity let's
say uh vosh
he's not a journalist but let's say one
day he decides to go confront stephen
crowder in front of his home
and says stephen you said this that or
otherwise and i want an answer from you
and you can see his home would you ban
him for that
or me doing that to david rockefeller
because i did that outside david
rockefeller's house so but i'm using
vodka yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
that's an exactly because a big user on
your platform if someone shows up in
front of his
his house where you can see his
neighborhood and everything and he's
questioning him would you ban that so if
it violates our policy we'll ban it and
like but the policy is very vague
yeah does that violate your policies so
this is something crowder's address so
this is a good question because like
the policies that we had since 2013
are vague and
we we've changed them to tighten them up
a little bit to try to get a little bit
more transparent a couple years ago
actually a year ago
and they're still not good enough it's
pretty much the same thing in spirit so
what we've done
is we're going to like that i mentioned
before is we're gonna we're bringing on
robert barnes viva fray and a bunch of
other free speech advocate lawyers to
help us really define these in in a way
that everybody can understand it for me
this is this is lawyer stuff like
i
if i go take it to our internal counsel
they're gonna make it as general as
possible vague as possible to make it as
as a custom and as good as possible for
for rumble but what i think
we could do differently and what i want
to do differently is
take it to the community have people
like yourselves have guys like robert
help us build this and really come up
with a solution and transparency around
these things that are vague because
they're you're right they're vague
absolutely but that's the nature of us
starting this business in 2013
not us uh as you know building this
platform in in the environment in the
last year so that that's something that
we
we're going to do and we're going to
address it and we're going to make it
clear i'm going to make it as
transparent as possible but i also think
this is the conversation everybody wants
us to have because it's like
you know it it it makes
they're very difficult questions to
answer so like whatever my policies are
here how do we make sure that we stay in
the play store
in the app store because they have
policies that are more vague than that
yeah and like it gets worse so so we'll
look um first i want to make sure it's
clear you're only getting you know these
these questions because you're allowing
them i mean google
youtube you know facebook they wouldn't
even come here and have these
discussions which is why it was so
insane because jack dorsey actually sat
down and had a conversation with with me
and joe but uh that being said
you have a rule number five you may not
post or transmit any message which is
abusive inciting violence harassing
harmful hateful anti-semitic racist or
threatening and so
there's interesting questions about what
abusive means what harassing means what
harmful means i understand you mentioned
absolutely but i will point out that
you've already adopted the narrative of
the left silicon valley tech giants
you've all before we've before anyone's
even joined your platform the rules you
already had in place already align with
silicon valley not entirely that's not
true um so the
what you're looking at is the same type
of stuff that was on youtube 10 years
ago
we didn't really have that many problems
on youtube 10 years ago did we
uh no no
i'm not i'm not sure they had these
specific of rules
definitely you could get away with a lot
in the early days but once
in terms of like racism and
anti-semitism that was on their platform
you were not allowed to do that um so
when it comes to
when it comes to the last two years
what's happened in the goal the way
they've moved and changed their terms is
this is like i said this is a
conversation they want us to have
because there's no answer to it and
these are just general terms and
conditions and we're going to address
this as as good as we possibly can by
bringing in the community to help us do
it but
the real conversation is rumble didn't
grow because these terms are there and
we're banning people
like we're not growing because there's
racist content on rumble that's that's
that's not part of rumble at all
rumble's growing because people can have
conversations that they could have at
the dinner table i think yeah but that's
now but you could ban people in the
future and then if you if you want
people to go to your network and put
their blood sweat and tears and whole
careers into your network you got to
give them some reassurance absolutely so
i i think the vague terms and services
are one issue but i think there's two
possible solutions here that i think
might be able to provide that and i
might be totally wrong about this but i
think having oversight transparency and
accountability especially when it comes
to destroying someone's livelihood
someone's entire business someone's
entire work would be something that
should be done in a transparent way
where people
get to decide what to do and not
some mysterious overlord that
mysteriously just clicks off and then
second would be possibly having you or
someone a part of the larger corporation
signing a contract pledging i will not
sell this stock i will uphold the first
amendment and if i don't do so i will
have to give all my stock to the users
or or chop off my right hand would you
be willing to sign an agreement like
that saying i promise not to sell the
majority of my stock i will uphold the
first amendment legally i i will
reassure you what you're reassuring us
today on a contract would you be willing
to sign that contract so who might sign
the contract with the the answers just
the general public with your users so
you're so instead of the user coming and
agreeing to your terms and services
you are agreeing to terms of services
for the users i would love to do
something like that that's a great idea
i think that's
that's a but that's a really good idea
to the circumstance that you will chop
off your right arm
you know we can make a vague one right
now i have a pen and paper we can make a
vague contract right now that could be
would you sign it right now on this show
what i was thinking about hold on would
you sign it right now on this show if i
say i
your name will chop off my hand if i
violate this and sell off the majority
you can't put it down and say yes and
you can say no but will you sign this
right now
chop his hand off come on i have a
question or a serious question sell off
sell off your stocks or give off your
stocks to uh the users that would just
make the problem worse yeah yeah it's
like that's like
i'm spending coercion basically yeah uh
i i got a question as you guys were
talking about your what you should how
you should handle your network i
realized like no one should own the
network rumble should be part of a group
of companies that are building a network
that is there for all of us to utilize
and that maybe we can help upkeep it all
of us but like i think of mines it's not
minds.com that's a social network that
was built by minds mines is a tech
company
so
that's i think the goal is to build a
network that i i so
you know one of the
concerns i had
when uh
locals you guys acquired locals which
was dave rubin's you know uh
subscription service
it's all good right it's good that these
platforms exist it's good that you guys
exist we use rumble for our uh website
as well we post our content here because
it's all it's all a net positive and um
you know aside aside from the fact that
we're asking hard questions the reality
is i trust you way more than i trust
youtube or any one of these other
platforms and i i think we're i don't
think you guys will end up but no it's
not it shouldn't be about trust we
should never have to trust that someone
has like not it's not personal at all at
all i don't want to be in control of
other people's life it should be i'm i
right right that's not the point i'm
getting to i'm saying
for now you know like i definitely would
would prefer uh you know use it i prefer
your guidance on or moderation over
youtube's for sure but the issue i have
is that centralization is still the main
problem
dave dave rubin launches locals and you
know he's signing people up and
everyone's like okay i'm gonna sign up
for this and i'm just i'm confused by it
i i i ask some of the people who signed
up i'm like how have you solved the
problem you haven't and they're like
well i know dave and i'm like yeah and
i've i've spoken with the ceo of patreon
on numerous occasions and he's made a
bunch of assurances to me and they're
like well i trust dave and i'm like okay
well if you don't trust the guy from
patreon because he's banned people you
do trust dave you're still in the exact
same position where dave can make all
the promises in the world just like jack
conti did and then you still get your
income nuked because when push comes to
shove visa approaches you know you guys
and says if you don't ban luke rotkowski
we will terminate financial services to
your firm you will say yes
uh that's not true because locals your
subscribers are in your own accounts not
ours
we don't control that what does that
mean it means when you get a
subscription on locals it goes into your
stripe account or whatever account
connected we don't have access to that
and so
what will end up happening is um
there will be
some level of infrastructure because
this is what actually happened to
patreon
they had i think was mastercard went to
patreon and said
ban this guy's name was um robert
spencer i think it was yeah he was uh
he's like a researcher on uh like jihadi
uh jihadism and stuff like that they
said ban him or we will
terminate your use of mastercard
financial services
does rumble and locals use visa and
mastercard financial services for any
part of their infrastructure the
subscriptions i you know through the oh
that's not what i asked i asked my
subscriptions not rumble specifically no
you you you not locals rumble as a
company doesn't use visa or mastercard
and we use
like for example stripe yeah they use
visa they use the swiss payment system
so how do you how does your company pay
for things if you don't use
are you talking about are you talking
about local subscriptions how that we're
talking about rumble and and and locals
as companies do they ever make
transactions using visa and mastery
absolutely and so what happens when they
come to you and they say ban this person
or else that's what happened to patreon
so if yeah so you know
if that happened to a locals user and
you know we had to ban a user because
they they asked us to ban whether we
would do it or not it's a whole
different story they've already tried
doing that with dan bongino and we told
them to pound sand um but let's say we
we did that just hypothetically
uh you still have your account with all
your subscriptions and your revenue
doesn't get nuked it's in your account
we don't control it
that's yours
yeah
and and that's so you can go port it and
build your own website and run it well
that's great that's how that's that's
how it functions currently that's that's
that's good but i still feel like you
know one of the things that i've i found
disconcerting
uh just in the long term process i think
everything we're hearing right now are
good short-term solutions but uh you
know ian pointed this out we're
effectively building the exact same the
exact same machine we've already had
problems with you know you have you
mentioned you have the same rules that
youtube had back in the day and i don't
disagree with a lot of the rules to be
completely honest i don't want
anti-semitic or racist crap you know
floating all over the place but i also i
i question why it is that
we're in this position where certain
people aren't allowed to express their
opinions even if their opinions are
really really awful you know what i mean
it's a very difficult position that
nobody wants to accept but i'll put it
this way
while i personally find anti-semitism
racism uh abhorrent
i don't feel that i should have the
authority to tell people that they
shouldn't be allowed to express their
opinions because in my view sunlight
being the best the best a disinfectant
challenging those ideas is important
except if you have too much too much
mold then sunlight even isn't gonna get
it that's a good point but it takes
everything but the real question the
harder question is how do you get around
the stores
to access the larger side of the market
we need our own well that's good
this is missing
or something absolutely but what we got
to get there first though so so this is
my how do we get there build a device
where we can have it pre-loaded visa and
mastercard have their own terms of
service which include much of the exact
same language banking institutions and
even companies you've never heard of and
don't realize you use have these same
terms of service so we've we've already
seen people debanked
and so the issue is even if you're
pledging we're not going to do these
things you're still a part of the big
machine and so for us the discussion we
had you know when when patreon banned
carl benjamin and this exodus happened
they had banned lawrence southern and
they banned carl benjamin sargon of
akkad and uh immediately i get you know
jordan peterson and dave rubin are
talking about doing the subscription
service and i said that doesn't solve
anything because what happened to
patreon wasn't like jack conte the ceo
one day said i don't want lawrence on
the platform he got external pressure
from business from company partners and
he he was put in this position where
he's like i don't know what i'm supposed
to do here because he's not a political
guy
carl benjamin got banned and he broke
his promise that he wouldn't just
terminate somebody so they decide to
make centralized platforms well ian and
i had a conversation and the only real
solution is complete decentralization
it's good that you guys unload that on
locals
you have your own stripe account with
all your subscriptions so even if
they're banned from locals they still
have stripes stripe would have to ban
them that's it yes that's that's that's
great that's fantastic but ultimately in
the end
there needs to be
uh in my opinion a way for people to
ultimately control their own hosting so
that they can't be banned because i'll
say this it does still feel like a half
measure it's good their revenue won't be
completely purged but now they have no
product and they have no place for it i
suppose they could then try and build a
website so what ian and i had discussed
was okay can we create can we create a a
a service that just instantly gives you
your own website so taking it one step
further how about
this is what i thought locals was going
to be i thought locals was going to be
that you'd sign up and you would just
get the code and you would have your own
website with your own domain and you
guys would have no ability to ban people
then i saw very quickly that it was the
same thing as patreon but now it's your
personal stripe account where the
accounts are getting logged in which
again better but still a centralized
platform if uh you know look when i talk
to some of the people that use locals i
ask them why they didn't just set up
their own stripe account on their own
website and never have to worry about it
again and they said i don't know how and
i'm like okay that's a good point but
that also means if you guys ban them
they don't know how they're not going to
just magically decide you know figure
out how to do it in which case to me the
solution was build a tech a function a
service an app software that allows
people to just click a button they set
up their own website and boom it's done
ready to go five minutes tops yeah and
then no one can ban them
yeah you're still gonna have to solve
for the hosting the video streaming
you're gonna there's a lot of things to
solve for in that that's uh yeah they'll
pay for it and they'll save money too
because locals takes more than uh the
amount of money that locals takes from
their creators exceeds the amount they'd
spend if they did it themselves are you
sure absolutely so what's the economics
there where are you running what kind of
the percentage that locals takes from
the from the creators
is more than it would cost for them to
host their own content
so if let's let's look at that um
if you're making there's economies of
scale for everything right and once you
get to a certain scale it makes sense to
to build it on your building on your own
um
and uh you know
let's take let's say you're doing ten
thousand dollars in billing or one
thousand dollars in billing a month does
it make sense to build it on your own
if locals is taking a hundred dollars
yes
you sure yes because if you uh if in the
in the long term so managing hosting
streaming yes
100
absolutely because you don't think it's
worth your time 100 bucks
so what you're doing right now is you're
convincing people to give you their
long-term prospects to basically put
themselves in a position where they're
beholden to your platform that's not
true
they own the subscriptions yeah they
still have if they could port their
rumble account to the fedoverse account
that we're building at and back and
forth just the locals account
so like whether they decide to do it
today or tomorrow they can do whatever
they can do whenever they but they need
a service that can function like rumble
that they can move it on to so how do
you notify all of your subscribers that
you're no longer on this platform and
that now you're moving to a new website
the reality is
you email them and it doesn't work it
doesn't work because you know look i've
been doing this for a long time i saw
how much money was lost by all the
people who jumped from patreon because
you will never be able to get 100 of
people subscribed to you to to be
notified it's not possible we've had
issues where
um we we weren't doing the show for
instance and i'll put on the youtube
channel for this reason we're off
tonight and i get emails like crazy like
where's the show and i'm like wow
i just assumed people would go to the
youtube channel and see the message
which is right there on the page but
they don't know you could have it when
they go to the band account it sends
instead of saying this account no longer
exists it says this account has been
banned and can be found at and then the
user is allowed to put in like a link
where they're going to go i don't know
if that's if that's considered a full
ban but that'd be cool so uh for for
those that are asking cause i see in the
chat
um we we we do have was it a functioning
alpha it's not quite i wouldn't call
it's not something you can play with yet
but it we're
quickly building out the early alpha
we're pre-alpha right now here here's
the the the issue they end up having
with everything is that
if someone
when someone comes to me and says we
want x percent of your revenue
and then you can be on our website
my issue is for a one-time investment
that is a small
you know small multiple of that number i
never have to worry about any of these
risks ever again i completely own
everything and we're good
if you sign up for locals
it's better than patreon in that you
mentioned it's your own stripe account
but then
in the future you're giving what's the
percentage that locals take let me ask
you 10 10 of your revenue let's say that
you decide you want to make a living
doing this content and local says we're
gonna take ten percent you say it's just
a hundred bucks it's a hundred bucks
except what happens if they hit a viral
video and within six months they have
six hundred thousand subscribers on you
know on youtube for instance that means
they end up with like ten thousand
people paying ten bucks a month now
they're giving you 10 000 per month for
hosting service which would cost them
maybe 500 or a thousand dollars
and you and sure you can leave whenever
you want good luck telling all of those
people
to port over to a new website to change
their routines it's extremely difficult
to do we could synchronize it so that
once they start getting enough hits and
they're making 10 000 and they're paying
a thousands too much they want their own
server now they can just kind of move it
over to their server still be on rumble
still be found all the analytics can
still go through rumble but they're now
hosting their own thing on their own
server i hear what people are saying too
you know because we've talked to people
and they said it's good to be on the
platform because there's like-minded
people and it's a community and i'm like
okay you know that i completely
understand i just feel like uh
you know for you guys obviously you need
to make money it's a business it's got
to generate profit
10
i think is just man i guess i'm too much
of a of a left in that capacity to me it
just feels like you're ripping people
off really i think you're both making
good points because at a low threshold
there's a value to it but once you
succeed a certain number of
subscriptions the it's overly costly i
think it's a lot of work to uh to manage
your own site and hire someone and then
connect it to aws and put the first of
all aws is a lot more expensive we
typical hosts like rumble but
we launched our website for
like a thousand bucks that's what the
software we're building basically does
that for you yeah and if you were to use
amazon for streaming video it'd be
significantly more expensive than it is
using rumble
well that we do use rumble i know so
like we're a little you know i'm like
very much you know critical in a lot of
respects but we absolutely do use rumble
but like we make it very cheap and we
make it very accessible in that sense
that it's you know if you were to go to
any other provider amazon is
significantly more expensive how do you
cheapen it
well we we own our own stuff we're not
reselling anything we're it's coming
straight off of us and we have economies
of scale when you have economies of
scale it uh it really brings down the
pricing and allows you to be aggressive
on things um a lot more aggressive than
anybody else as in like virtual servers
that you open up
uh yeah so like you know we have you
know rumble does so much bandwidth um
that uh
we're able to
get it at uh prices that are from
carriers that are much cheaper than what
you you'd pay if you think if you enter
amazon you're paying at eight cents a
gig a rumble at scale when you're coming
to us you're like eight times cheaper um
well this is this is this is fascinating
actually because you are you are a
rumble and you're locals and we use
rumble for our members only content yeah
and we we we post a rumble because it's
a great service and it's substantially
less expensive than your your
competition and i don't have to worry
about
uh censorship to a certain degree like
obviously we're asking these questions
but locals is still something different
and
having used your infrastructure and
seeing how cheap it is to host per gig
and then to see how much locals takes
from the creators i'm like
you see it's kind of it's kind of
strange to me seeing both sides of it
right yeah it's significantly better
than twitch or youtube um on locals uh
in terms of
the cut that it's taking it's it's
actually quite low
but so so for me
when um you know
obviously i was looking at locals before
you guys acquired them
i know how much it costs us to host
these videos i know how much it's going
to cost us if we were using vimeo at one
point we switched to you guys because
honestly it was better and vimeo is
risky for our business because of their
their staff yeah so we don't want to do
that but so i'm looking at we put up a
video for members only here's how many
views we get in the members only video
here it's actually i'll tell people who
are listening it's decently expensive
because we have so many subscribers
but the subscribers are paying so you
know the costs it covers the cost of all
that allows us to have journalists and
make this robust website then i take a
look at you know so so very early on
when we were looking to build the
website i see all the costs i'm mapping
all the stuff and i've been in this
business for you know a decade plus and
then i see locals and they're like
here's how much we want from you to do
the same thing and i'm like oh that's
absurd it's obscene the amount of money
you'd end up taking is ridiculous
and then i see all of these people
signing up
and so i'm not i'm not trying to drag
you guys because i think it's good that
locals exist i think it's good that
rumble exists and we use rumble i'm just
saying i think the long-term solution is
actually
not any of this well the functionality
is definitely a long-term solution but
it's the way that it's
co built like if it's proprietary then
it's going to get co-opted at some point
when you either decide to quit or die or
sell or whatever the hell something's
going to happen eventually one day
you'll no longer be
so then it's going to go into somebody
else's hands and if they control it then
we still need the function we just need
access to the functionality 24 7
uninterrupted
people should be watching your stuff
yeah and one of the things about you
know the rumble cloud that that we're
coming out with is that
you know this is a service that can
support whatever you guys are building
if you guys are
are building something that's good for
deploying it you know people don't have
to use locals they should have choice
they should be able to use other things
and like use locals too
you know we're
we're providing that cloud and that's
that's we know we'd love to work with
you guys on that too and when you say
that cloud can you explain exactly like
what is the hardware so we're we're
building pops across the united states
uh
oh now okay there's a better question
for my uh
for for someone else on my team but uh
the i think it's point of uh something
um and so we have data centers across
the us and we're putting in our own
hardware our own switches and connecting
to carriers post office protocol pop pop
like when you set up your okay something
different i think it's something
so you're building servers
yeah so we're putting in our own
hardware our own switches routers and
stuff and data centers across the united
states multiple different places we're
looking to have uh
you know i think five in total by the
end of this year five data centers yes
um we're at three right now so
uh
it's it's a big job it's something that
uh
we we we took on early last year and uh
we're trying to accelerate that as fast
as possible and then make that service
available for what you guys are doing
like it doesn't
i understand i understand some people
might not like the 10 fee and that's
totally fair like if there's another
solution that that can do better than
that then that's great for the for the
market and uh you know if we can be a
provider on the bandwidth side because
we're the best the most competitive on
that on that side that's the way we
should work i think another way to
counter that if you are taking 10
showing people where the money is going
to
i think will also provide a level of
oversight and and some people gladly
being like yeah i'll give 10 when i know
exactly what it's going towards and i i
think there's another aspect here that
is worth mentioning here because a
couple years ago julian assange released
information that was accurate and he got
punished by paypal he got punished by
all the credit card processors and they
shut down his ability to raise funds for
his independent media organization um
you know it would be very interesting to
ask you what you would do in that
situation but but not even just going
there would you be potentially
interested in providing some kind of
alternatives to the current financial
system regarding cryptocurrencies and
bitcoin that's there as a plan b
just in case if they do squash down on
you you could say they can't shut us all
down because we have this alternative
which is related to bitcoin or
cryptocurrency yeah so on the crypto
side we need to do something there and
i've been looking i've been trying to
study it i i think i wanna
whatever we decide to do needs to
provide immense value to the creator and
to the user not
that's key number one and i think a lot
of the stuff that you're seeing out
there right now is providing immense
value to whoever creates that token yeah
um and i don't really like that so until
like we can find a real viable way and
i'm looking and i'm seeing what people
are launching in the video space and a
whole bunch of different other things
um
once once there's something there i we
need to adopt it and when that
technology in tech gets there we we need
to definitely adopt it it's probably
there um i think what's happening when
you're talking about the ponzi scheme is
where a creator will create a bunch of
tokens and they hold most of them in
their own personal wallet and then
slowly they get send them out there and
they just become massively rich but like
what mines did is create a utility token
that it keeps in an account that it
doesn't have access to none of the
people have access to it and every day
it spreads out like 10 000 tokens to the
community
there there was a really good i forget
the site they tried to compete against
twitter um
it was like something that started with
a b
i think like michael arrington and a few
of these anderson horowitz was behind it
and it was like
what they did is they basically said
like
every single creator will have its own
token and based on like how much
following and how many people how much
people want to donate to that creator
their their token has a higher value in
price
by creator i thought that was pretty
interesting you'd have to build software
where you could spin up your own token
really quick someone could spin up a
utility token yeah that allows like you
if you pay in subscriptions to the user
you pay 10 bucks a month but if you pay
with pay them with their own token you
get a discount of their choice they get
to set a discount level and that'll
create utility value for the token
and then it's not a security so the sec
doesn't isn't as concerned about it yeah
we'll we definitely need to to look
deeply into into the whole crypto world
on rumble and figure out blockchain and
figure out what is the best way to
approach that
it's just
we're we're in i guess the early days of
it and uh
i haven't quite seen the perfect
solution yeah i don't know if we're
going to wait for a perfect solution but
something that's going to provide some
really good value to the community on
the minds token it's one token gets you
a thousand views of of basically
advertising on the network and on
library you put tokens into a video and
then that elevates it in the search
algorithm the more tokens it has so it's
like a passive boosting if you could
blend those somehow or utilize both
i think the the big challenge with any
platform no matter what you do is that
you're responsible for the platform you
are allowing people to post stuff
whatever it is
and so
you know what happens if someone posts
an address
now you might say oh section 230 but
you're still going to get sued and so a
lot of these companies just don't want
to deal with it and that's why you end
up in this position i think it's
personal identifiable information or
something like that and violates
something i don't know i'm not a lawyer
but i think the one of the issues with
youtube for example if you are an
independent reporter and you confront
someone in front of their home they'll
ban you if you're cnn you get away with
it why because youtube's going to be
like cnn this is your problem you deal
with it and cnn's probably going to say
sure we're worth billions of dollars we
don't care either no one's going to do
anything to us
but it's different in that
in reality if you're walking down the
street and you're waving a sign
it's public property so who are you
gonna sue the person waving the sign
on social media they'll sue you anyway
section 230 be damned so that's i think
this is one of the reasons many of these
platforms are going to implement these
rules no matter what
that if you're james o'keefe and you
walk up to the ceo of a company and say
you know we want to ask you some
questions
that's why central control of authority
seems to always lead to this
totalitarian crackdown of its of its net
with its own network i think that's why
you just got to get rid of the control
of the network and kind of oversee its
construction and and survival but allow
it to function on its own i think maybe
uh community policing and stuff we need
to have some kind of
i don't know
i don't know if twitter or
it's got to be some kind of public
utility communications platform because
we don't use the city hall anymore we
don't use town hall we don't have these
public commons it's controlled by
interests people who either you know can
afford to build the platform or who do
so but don't want to take responsibility
for the things put on the platform in
which case
until we can say this is a public you
know institution you can't sue anyone
for hosting it but you can sue the
person who said it or did it or file a
complaint against them that's when i
think we actually start fixing these
problems for the time being
you youtube will get twitter gets sued
when someone does something you know
what i mean even with section 230
they're like so we don't want to take
responsibility and put ourselves at risk
for hosting this so until we i don't
know i don't know if nationalizing is
the answer but until we have a platform
absolutely having a national platform
would be cool in addition to others but
so look canada tried that within cbc but
i understand you're you're aversion to
nationalization of
there is a value to having one national
right but take a look at
a public park the police can come in and
tell you to leave you can complain about
it they can arrest you it's annoying and
sometimes people like they should be
allowed to do it but who are you gonna
sue the city i guess okay well that
makes sense if the city does something
specifically but if someone is in a park
holding up a sign with a picture of like
a fetus or something you can't do
anything about it people are allowed to
express themselves what's wrong with
common carriers
why isn't that solution then maybe that
is a solution like verizon at t they're
uh they they're they're deemed to be
common carriers they're they're
monopolies that's one problem with them
but they are but they are common
carriers they don't stop you from buying
the phone no matter who you are but they
will send your text messages to the nsa
without a batting an eye
and the security camera filming the park
will send all of the video and as you're
walking down the street the surveillance
state is a problem and of itself but uh
that that could be the solution i feel
like you know that's one of the things
that we want to make rumble cloud
closest to is make it a common carry
like close to as common carrier as
possible i think that that that could be
a solution yeah we'll build a parallel
system and people will be like oh that
works better than this old
carrier system this is the internet
telephone market blended into one
instead of them trying to give people
phone numbers what the heck like that's
20th century tech you don't need a
number associated yeah what if everyone
just started instead of getting phone
numbers you just got like your handles
yeah or your name or you like you yeah
give me a call you know at tim cast and
then they press it like i don't i don't
give out my phone number anymore it's
like hit me up on facebook instagram
like message me on some of these i'll
video chat you on element yeah i only
get i only get phone calls from people
who want to talk to me about my car's
extended warranty or who are talking to
me in mandarin for some reason i had an
idea before we go to super chats chris
when uh regarding if you're
headquartered in florida and canada gets
you like hey this is illegal in canada
so we're not going to show it in canada
take it down you tell them what we do at
mines you tell them no
it's legal this is our terms and if the
country wants to ban rumble from the
country they will and that's unstoppable
that'd be hilarious
we're already banned in a few countries
china china i believe china
so yeah i think iran probably
i'm not sure but definitely china we got
to notice that we got shut off in china
so google
built their own chinese i don't know
dragonfly is that what it was called
their own chinese google didn't they go
and do that when google didn't want them
in the country because they were too
free yeah it led to a revolt but google
when china that's an interesting thing
you cut you cut off the service in the
country that doesn't want to play fairly
and once they become like that then then
maybe you cut them off social media is
an interesting it's more powerful
countries the social media companies
like if imagine google said hey we're
not going to operate in canada because
you you know you don't operate around
the first amendment and that's easy that
sounds pretty good i like that idea
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already get that super chat in we'll be
reading as many as we can smash the like
button go to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only segment
at timcast.com around 11 p.m let's read
what you guys
have to say
jemis says please shout out the january
23rd anti-vaxx mandate protest with dr
robert malone do you know the website
url i don't but what is it
march against the mandates dc right i
don't know google search march against
the mandates and they're doing a big
protest in dc
so uh good good for that man
it is
defeatthemandatesdc.com oh nice i
believe that's it gerald armstrong says
how many times do we have to hear ian
say i co-founded minds probably in the
next year probably
37 more times well i think what people
need to understand is maybe less maybe
20. hasn't met these people
and so if they're trying to understand
where his con what the context of what
he's saying and they're like i met this
you know crazy hippie guy ian why should
i listen to him and then he says i
actually worked on minds i'm trying to
balance when you're on tv every night um
basically if i told the story a year ago
in me in my mind i already told you
everyone that's listening you already
know but a lot of times we have new
listeners so you want to reiterate and
sometimes tim will tell you about occupy
wall street just in case you haven't
heard you know it's kind of a meme that
it can be overdone too so if i'm
overdoing it i'm sorry but
i'm still going to tell people that i'm
the co-founder of minds all right let's
read some more we got the meaning of
nerd he says hey tim the meaning of nerd
here thanks for checking out my video
i'm really glad you liked it and thanks
for sharing it on twitter it helped out
a lot keep inspiring people the way you
have men p.s if you're looking for an
editor i would love to offer my skills
we had a few people ask for jobs
and then it turned out they weren't
american and we can't hire people who
aren't american citizens and yeah we
just can't do it um man if you guys
really want to get angry at google and
facebook look at how the the the you
know how the the visa system works right
like h1bs yeah how the big tech
basically just floods the entire system
so that they get them all and you can't
even bother
that's just the way it works i guess
all right john hensley says love rumble
is there any way to get the mobile app
to play always on top and minimized or
with uh screen off
coming coming very soon that's an
important one we get a lot of people
saying like i want to listen to the show
on the website it depends on android
that's already happening i believe um
and on ios uh you can have it set i have
to double check but that should be
available in this new launch that we're
coming with the with the app on ios
if you use the brave browser on mobile
my understanding is that it can play
audio from the browser
yeah that's that's really fantastic
useful yeah you know i love the brave
app they're doing a lot of great things
those guys are great are you guys
integrating with them at all have you
had a chance to chat with them uh we
haven't chatted with them but uh we
we've been looking at it as well is
there any other cross-collaboration with
any other kind of alternative
independent kind of
platforms or in the works or possibly
that you might be even interested in
no i'm interested in collaborating with
any with anyone for sure uh i think
there's a lot of great ideas out there
that we need to any specific companies
or
uh i haven't i like brave brave has been
very interesting um in terms of like how
they've been doing their crypto and the
bat the bat i i did look very closely at
that we're we're actually looking very
closely at that right now the app spun
off the dissenter browser off of the
brave browser that's pretty cool looking
did you guys hear uh quebec is doing a
vax tax yeah unvax tax attacks for the
unvaxxed instead of mandating it that's
crazy that's insane i have friends in
quebec that
i'm praying that they're going to be
okay because they're talking about hefty
fines for individuals who just want
bodily autonomy that's a new level of
tyranny that
the world has it's like evidenced bodily
autonomy at this point
there's a lot of evidence that the
vaccines don't stop the virus that it
doesn't even stop the spread of the
virus it might reduce symptoms so like
it's there's reason to this it's not
just it don't get away from me for no
reason like there's a lot of data
nick rowe says tim do a fouchy
impression if he actually were a guest
on irl
after you ask him a question what his
response would be that's a job for
sheamus if uh sheamus of freedom tunes
wants to write that up that could be you
know fairly funny i suppose
dr fauci
on irl tough interview
all right nate parrott says my work
plays for news in break room i walked
past and the screen was black with white
scrolling text that stated the channel
was showing restricted content weird oh
my
strange what is that about
all right where we where we go
anzu love says watch rogan's show with
adam curry he clears up malone's
explanation of mass psychosis
i love that guy
yeah adam curry man i love that guy
omg puppy says watch sens century of the
self by adam curtis cur let's say curis
same person right great documentary
about social engineering from freud to
neuro-linguistic programming used by
bill clinton to campaign what's the
documentary called
century of the self
here's an important one
daryl 90210 says ask about the success
of salty cracker pulling viewers away
from youtube please
interesting yeah so uh i like i think uh
what a lot of salty cracker character
yeah
so they they have channels on youtube i
believe and uh what they do is they shut
off the stream after 30 minutes and ask
them or i'm not sure the timing and i
want to say that because i don't know
but uh
yeah they they use rumble and uh they're
quite big
yeah they get um tens of thousands of
viewers i think is that what it is yeah
wow yeah well there's a there's a bunch
of them that get like crowder does a
significant amount uh what does crowder
get when he streams on rumble
he was in december he was hitting 50 000
wow um i think he just came back today i
didn't take a look but yeah but he's
back on youtube today i'd like to do a
live stream on rumble at some point
that's all it's all set up to do that
yeah
that'd be fun well i suppose people have
to just take a look at salty crackers
content on rumble and youtube to better
figure out because uh you know
to get to get a better assessment of of
what the channel's about and why they're
so successful
uh i do notice that people post the salt
emojis all the time so right i'm not
completely unaware
weavey says i don't buy for a second
that social media censors in order to
not scare advertisers where else are
they going to advertise advertising
isn't pulling out of spaces with that
large of an audience i completely agree
with that
absolutely and also if you're
advertising with google or youtube as an
advertiser you have the right to say i
don't want to advertise with this
content creator you could easily do that
through the back through the back door
you could easily do that through of
course just clicking hey i don't like
this this this idea i don't want it
associated with this and this and this
you could easily do that you don't need
to censor people's voices chris bill
ottman texted me and was like ask chris
a question so i'm going to ask you hey
he's cheating why do you super chat why
do you use google analytics which spies
on all users for google it's a good
question we got to get rid of it
we went through that with mines in the
earlier yeah so what's your it's just so
easy to use it's what we use when we
started in 2013 and
we just you know these are legacy things
from when we started in 13 that we
definitely need to to move what's your
roadmap to move away from that
well we want to dump that that's for
sure and
there's a few other solutions out there
and open to recommendations if anybody
wants to super chat some ideas we're
open to ideas on that front
all right captain says what is the
policy on gun videos on rumble youtube
has been demonetizing gun videos that
have high capacity magazines and more it
is stifling gun culture that was created
on that platform there's no policy
around that
there's nothing in our terms about guns
so if i bought like a hand crank nine
millimeter gatling artillery thing that
luke's trying to get me to buy we could
put a rumble
and there's no issue uh i i i'm i'm not
too familiar with what that is but uh if
i'm not entirely either be honest that
sends me this thing it's like tim buy
this it's a weapon that goes
all right
that's what it is no there there's a
crank there's a millimeter gatling
there's quite a few channels um with uh
with respect to hunting and guns and
stuff like that on rumble no issues
another person asked a similar question
restless medic says i'm a native
floridian and my fiance is canadian i'd
much rather live up there with him
because like tim said i can put on more
clothes if i'm cold i can only take so
many off before it becomes a felony yeah
but how much how much communism can you
deal with that's the larger question
exactly exactly i would i would i would
take
uh a permanent 100 degree day at maximum
humidity and freedom over communist snow
well
you can't even you can't even leave your
house right now in canada it's nuts
everything's shut down you can't go to a
restaurant
you're stuck at home
like that that's house arrest are you
staying in the states for a while uh
well i'm here right now i'm heading to
florida tomorrow so i'm excited
freedom is a great thing
like i said earlier when the plane got
off the ground in canada this is a good
feeling
nice the real fallen demon says i'm a
very heavy minds user and it's great but
ian mate the ui is bad i'd build my own
client but there's no real api for it
you could give devs more than just
source we could make it amazing
well
man i haven't worked at the company in a
while
bill's listening apparently what's up
bill
i love you um
i don't know so you're looking for an
easy way to to spin up the system
because you don't have the api is that
what he said he doesn't have he wants to
make his own ui i would love it i hear
that a lot from people that the minds ui
is just bad it's just a bunch of back
end code yeah well yeah the ui it kind
of looks like it's very um
like clean and like sterile almost like
it's like a robot like everything is
straight lines and kind of boxes of
information that's not bad it's just
there's so much going on there's a lot
going on it's tough so you gotta know
where to collect ui is really hard like
we
we have issues with our ui too we get a
lot of complaints about that and you
know when you're when you're a
bootstrapped company hey we didn't get
investment until 2021 that was like the
first time i remember people laughing us
out of the room in 2013 to say that
we're going to compete against youtube
i'm sure they want to be in now but
that's a different story but like when
it came to ui it's uh
you know we we really couldn't really
forward that and get really deep into
that until we could afford people that
would that are really good and they're
very expensive and uh you know we have
that and now we're coming up with it so
but like i understand that that's that
that's a you gotta it's expensive
there's a lot of people that really good
talent that a lot of the big companies
suck up
and uh it it's a it's a tough thing to
to to really get good yeah and it's also
like an artistic choice how you want to
design your use that that too like you
know you got sites like you know drudge
and reddit that don't didn't really go
into that direction of ui and then you
got you know nicer things like uh
instagram that came up with all these
flat designs and cool designs which
people now desire quite a bit and tick
talk and all that so you know we're
putting a lot of money into that and
it's not cheap be cool if you could
design your own ui on the website while
you use it as a user yeah well what what
things like
things
what if you could log in and then while
you're editing your profile put in like
html code even like mp3s
music maybe have like glitter and like
hulk hogan just like a space where you
could do that yeah yeah you could like
make it like your own space yeah your
your space would you call it your space
mughal minion says ian have you read
into exo politics if so do you have any
book recommendations no i have not well
maybe you should eat i think i might you
should d e poland says tim being in
florida for one year makes you a snow
bird tourist and we do go outside we
also have springs with pure water miami
is southern new york
so i lived in miami for a year just over
a year
and in january and february i saw people
all over the place throughout the year
everybody was at miami beach i saw them
outside all over the place but
through all these neighborhoods
and at like you know shopping centers in
the summer everybody was indoors and the
windows were soaking wet because the the
air conditioning inside the con the
humidity outside it would condense and
it was just all the windows were always
drenched and i'm pretty sure there's a
statue of the guy who invented air
conditioning in miami is that is that
true i'm not sure but i was told
probably so yeah carrier or something
the guy who invented the air
conditioning invented air conditioning
gets a statue hey man good for him i
looked at what exo politics is the study
of key individuals political
institutions and processes associated
with extraterrestrial life
interesting interesting that's a real
thing hodl rodeo says bitcoin magazine's
live stream on youtube was stopped and
the channel was removed today the
channel was later restored that is crazy
man the way that i heard about that an
admins mistake can disrupt a user's
life like their their income because the
day your video goes up is when you get
most of the views if it's demonetized
for that day because of some idiot doing
the wrong thing it's just devastating to
that i got to deal with this all the
time um and it's not even that's the
automated system though so it used to be
that every video i'd make would be
demonetized and then they finally backed
off and fixed this problem but now you
still get it and what happens is i'll i
did like a video on fauci and they said
it was harmful pranks
and then i've got to email google and
then you know three days later they get
back to me and say sorry about that and
i'm like oh the video made no money
three days later i might as well not
even bother emailing you but the issue
is the more videos get demonetized the
more they do monetize you could you
imagine something you've got to send
them all in and say fix it if they had
to pay you back for all the ads revenue
you would have made if a company had to
pay back for miss miss administrative
ship man but they're not making money
that's the problem like youtube wants to
make money
they also have political issues for sure
but they want to make money so they
don't like it when you know when i get
demonetized they were like oh we're so
sorry this keeps happening to you it's
the automated system and it's like yeah
and it takes three days to get it fixed
even when i can email google
so that's that's on them i suppose they
lose money
whatever that's why i think you know
rumble is good that's why we've set up
the website that's why we're focusing on
an editorial the editorial side of
things we can't just think you know
we're going to be on this platform
forever youtube at a certain look it's
2022.
we've been we've been swatted we've been
hit with a ddos attack good times what
and it's it's only the 11th of january
it's been a good month
yeah how about that man
so we've got a bunch of crazy
redundancies and backup systems and
everything like that security so but
it's just you know this is why we got
swatted all people noticed a cop walk by
and then walk out because we do have
layers of security here
all right
james lamb says i personally think it's
great for overt communists to voice
their opinions opinions shows everyone
how bad communism really is i agree
absolutely
yeah it's crazy i saw um kim iverson
tweeted she's like a center-left
youtuber that she's voting straight
republican love her
and then i saw vash respond to a tweet
about it saying this is totally you know
unexpected and shocking or whatever and
i'm just kind of like
when the center left is jumping ship to
join republicans and you mock them on
the way out like are you just trying to
lose on purpose you know
i guess
but kim's cool
i'm not surprised she's voting
republican because so many people are
like i'm done with the mandates she got
red pilled hard the last couple years
that was awesome well it's not that it's
the mandates i mean but yeah the past
couple years all of a sudden she's like
i'll vote for anybody who's gonna end
this yeah we're having her back soon
yeah oh good i i don't disagree she's
great we need to uh you know build a
cloning machine and bring a bunch of
more desantis's all over the country so
that we can end this stuff
i don't i don't think texas texas does
an okay job but it seems like that's
mostly about you know culture cultural
pressure the xander seems to be on top
of things to be honest you know
all right
raymond g stanley jr says we're a based
audience we see into the future
wow
i'd believe i like it
all right
the wholesome grail says how is it a
free speech platform if they ban racist
or hateful speech isn't racist speech
still legal even if you don't like it
not good if the free speech guy already
has racism banned
like i said that's uh something that we
put in since uh 2013 we've we've always
done that we haven't moved the goalposts
we we've stayed with the same moderation
since day one and we need to be better
and we need to uh we need to be really
transparent with these terms and we need
to do something different than these
other platforms did this this is not
something i predicted to happen
um in this world this is something that
you know things happened really fast in
the last two years where they started
banning all kinds of political talk etc
um but we gotta we we gotta come up with
something that's new and something
that's stronger and it's better and more
resilient and more and more in line with
free speech and that's what we're gonna
do yeah like um
trying to administrate like
gross stuff like like gore or like
racism
because it's tough because for in a free
speech world it would all be there and
anyone that wants to look for it's going
to find it because they have the right
granular search mechanisms but in in the
social media world right now it's like
waking up in the morning and it's there
in front of your face and you're like ah
and everywhere you look there's just
more gore and so unless an admins
they're deleting it or or blocking it
even though it's not illegal
people are going to be deformed by it
it's it's it's a new thing huh
humans didn't used to deal with this
until 15 years ago yeah it's really like
one of the most complicated issues of
our time right now is is really kind of
understanding this and and navigating
this in in the way that we're trying to
do and i think like our approach and why
we've grown is just being consistent and
not changing things in the last couple
years i think one of the way of dealing
with this is just by letting people see
what they subscribed to and not curating
an algorithm would that be something
that you guys that's what we're doing
we're a chronological feed we don't have
an algorithm that's uh putting things up
based on
you know how
interesting your content on how many
likes
or how many re-engagements it gets it's
a chronological feat that's all it is
and you guys will be changing your terms
and services
yeah so we're we're going to bring on
guys like aviva fray and
robert barnes like i said and uh we're
gonna we're gonna work on uh coming up
with like whether it's like a
constitution or terms all kind of
combined something very new something
something kind of built from the
community more for more than i would
love to be a part of that process yeah
absolutely like uh you know we'll we'll
bring you in on that like this is
something it is something we really need
to solve for and
um like i said we're we haven't solved
for it we didn't even think we needed
salt who thought we were gonna sit here
and worry about the first amendment in
2022 yeah yeah like there's that problem
of being the guy who's like we should
allow people to be racist on our
platform it's like nobody man
nobody wants that that's not why
rumble's growing we don't allow that
it's not there's not even a percent of
that doesn't exist on our platform so
the challenge is
you know when uh
oliver darcy of all people wrote an
article about me when i said banning the
alt-right was bad because it's a
slippery slope you want you want bad
ideas to be fleshed out so we can
challenge them and um but but
to be the person who then comes out and
says reinstate all of the racists and
bring them all back on is a step further
now and people don't want to do it
in my opinion though as much as i think
all of you know i think a lot of people
have a lot of really bad opinions we
just need a space where people of all
different backgrounds and ideas no
matter how awful or how good they might
be they can they can have those debates
i i think you know
you know i really believe
it's good to know who's bad
and not hide them when you hide people
that are bad
that that makes them better yeah that
doesn't help them i mean that helps them
it doesn't help us we we should know who
who we should know everything about
everybody if they are willing to scream
it out loud yeah at the end of the day
that's how i feel personally about it
but when you guys are doing um your your
terms revamp check out the manila
principles i don't know if you've heard
of them but it's like basically an
internet constitution that's been worked
on by the community you know it's very
cool you know what mines does the jury
system
i've heard it's cool i i don't know
about mines but i've heard jerry is some
jury system yeah so what will happen is
if a piece of content gets reported by
someone that goes into a queue which is
then sent to anyone that wants to opt
into this jury system on mines and then
it goes out to like 12 random jurors
that then vote on is does this violate
terms or does it not violate you
but you get poisoned by bias in the jury
yeah and then some people will say i
like this content so but they don't
they're not doing it right because
they're not saying does it violate the
terms or does it not validate terms and
then so there's noise so but over time
does it go through a minds filter first
like minds thinks it's bad and mine
doesn't even touch it and just a user
reports it and it goes into this queue
that people want to be a part of anyway
so it's not bothering anyone and then
they we just over time if someone abuses
their position in the queue as a juror
they're no longer able to be a juror
that's a really interesting idea maybe
even having it go like if
if let's say a rumble moderator wants to
remove something if something's going to
get removed or someone's going to get
banned take it to a jury the downside
for the final outcome except for if it's
illegal because that's a really
interesting idea if it's illegal you got
to get it out of there immediately well
if it's illegal absolutely
sort of stasis yeah something yeah
but so but but also i think that one of
the issues with mine is that jerry pool
needs to be way bigger than 12. i think
so too yeah you'll see that 100 people
uh or more thousands i mean
whatever whoever is available
yeah that's a really good idea i really
like that in fact you can even have like
a tab that says jury pool and
you know you can opt in and then get
like a blurred thing and says like okay
click it to show the image because
people
people have to have to opt in have to go
to the space maybe even you have it at
the bottom because they're going to see
some really awful stuff there'll be some
really bad stuff yeah what you want to
do is you want to you want to kind of
filter out the illegal stuff and the
overt stuff and then when it comes to
the controversial
and very vague stuff then then you take
it to a jury that way the vague stuff is
determined by the community not
determined by any overlords and if the
jury gets like the arbiter are true if
they get it wrong the user can appeal
again goes to a new jury of all fresh
people if they get it wrong the juror
can appeal again a third time if they
get it wrong again then they can go to
the admin then they can go to mother
mine's admins and appeal
and so do a lot of people appeal it
or yeah a lot of people think they've
been wronged regardless and they'll
usually appeal it but it's fun for the
jurors so it seems to be working really
well yeah i think as long as you have
good protections for like how you opt
into the jury because people are going
to see some really nasty stuff mm-hmm
yeah 18 plus
yeah and you gotta go
and then and then maybe the jury should
actually have like an emergency hit it's
gonna this is gonna be so it's like does
it violate the rules yes it's gone no it
doesn't and are you wearing a seat belt
we're solving the internet emergency
admin notification because if someone
posts like a crime or like a murderer or
something oh yeah you need to be able to
immediately be like yo this is beyond
this is like warning violates and is
illegal could be yeah yes perfect yeah
but i think i wonder if like
it shouldn't even be does it violate the
rules should it be should this be
allowed on the platform
that's another question this one's more
is it it's more like does it define the
terms or is it against the terms but
should it be that's another cool ideas
like i think we could experiment with a
platform where it's like people just
decide should it be allowed or not and
so someone could see something they'll
flag it and then they'll be like should
it be allowed and then 100 people see it
and if the majority say it's allowed
it's allowed and then have the ai write
an algorithmic terms of service based on
the behavior
i don't know about that 800 rules
there's like free software if a cat
sneezes your band for seven days
and then the ai takes over the world and
then dominates all of human civilization
so it's a lot smarter than everyone else
which of course could be the next
nuclear weapon but that's another story
i just wish we had a platform that's
allowed all speech and allowed me as an
individual to be responsible for myself
and have discernment i would love that
it's the problem is is is admit is like
organism is order within because that
creates there's so much chaos that then
the loudest if i want to subscribe to
something i'm going to subscribe to it i
don't have to i don't have to subscribe
to somebody but i don't want to listen
but when screaming
gets in the way and you can't even see
that i'm not going to subscribe to him
but he's in the way of you so he's not
no he's not i subscribe to who who i
want to subscribe to he's not going to
be in my way because i'm not going to
follow him because i don't want the
screaming guy in my in my inbox what
about the comments
i don't free speech let them comment
whatever they want like i i don't censor
comments people criticize me good great
i love it spam you know we need comments
we need people spam yes um
fine
let them let people spam no no i'd be
down
there's a big difference between
trolling and spamming yes
trolling's fine
when people are speaking at a college
and then someone goes in and starts
screaming at the top of their lungs i'm
like you can leave
like
it's a comment section right so people
get to upload whatever comments they
like and they don't like like so the
chat we have the one the one rule i say
i'm like i don't care if you're saying
whatever you want to say like i don't
know youtube will ban you if you say
something whatever but the spam is the
problem because you're stopping other
people from from saying what they want
to say so i'm like i want more free
speech
if you're going to try and disrupt that
free speech then i think we can ask you
to leave yeah i would respectfully i i
would respectfully kind of disagree and
let it play out and have a little bit
more chaos and kind of accept that and
understand i think spam spam is an issue
for sure that needs to be addressed but
in terms of like i think the creators
should be responsible for the
the their comments and choose what they
want there and what they don't want
there that would be the
the best i think
yeah that's true too every creator every
every creator you know controls their
own space in their own home it's not my
home it's your home
exactly we got a whole bunch of uh super
chats with salt emojis
the salty the salty we should get him on
the show
because i'm seeing a lot of it yeah i'm
seeing a lot of salt from the chat yeah
yeah he's really big on rumble he's uh
he's got a big stream on rumble not the
biggest but he's uh he's definitely a
big one um right on who are the biggest
users on rumble right now
dan bongino is by far the biggest um he
crushes it uh crowder not there yet um
the biggest livestream we have on rumble
is donald trump oh well that's right
yeah that makes sense so what he did
his network or 500 000 live streamers he
can hit on his rallies
i don't think i and that's post election
but is that trump's account or is that
yeah that's on donald trump's official
account on rumble so they were building
a social network are they just hosting
their back end on rumble is that what
that is or is this a different thing
yeah we'll be there cloud infrastructure
for truth social oh cool but this is
something different that he's using
right now he's got his so he came on to
rumble in june uh i guess so six months
ago he opened his official account on
rumble to uh do his uh rallies
and uh he hits numbers that
will just i've never seen like and
nobody's even close the power of uh of
his live streams hitting a half a
million on rumble and he's not promoting
it on twitter or anything anymore
because he doesn't have any accounts
so he he people come they watch and and
this is post-election too i can't even
imagine if i don't think we would have
been able to handle his live stream
infrastructurally if it was uh
pre-election times but uh dude virtually
we almost went down on his first stream
we went to like 100 capacity and we were
ready to shut off countries one by one
just to keep the stream up in the united
states oh that's how that's how big it
was all right everybody smash that like
button if you have not already and go to
timcast.com sign up because we're gonna
have a members only podcast coming up
around 11 or so p.m uncensored behind
the scenes don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show the url post it wherever
you can if you really if you really want
to help us out you can follow the show
tim castaire basically everywhere follow
us on instagram for clips you can follow
me at tim cast chris you want to shout
anything out
uh you can follow me on rumble
chrisrumble i'm also on twitter chris
rumble
at chris pavlovsky on twitter i should
say and then the the rumble account as
well as i think it's rumble video rumble
video on twitter chris thank you so much
for coming thank you for
answering our questions and uh taking
the questions i know a lot of other kind
of you know big tech ceos don't do that
so i appreciate you for doing that
and it's good to at least have this
dialogue anyway i have my own media
organization called we are changed it's
available on we are change.org i also
made a very interesting video on
lukeuncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there and uh thank you so much
for having me well you're welcome you
looked right at me when you said that i
liked that bye everyone i'm ian
crossland checkmationcross.net chris
great to see you man tim i love you hi
lydia hi yeah i'm still alive in the
corner despite my coughing fit very
sorry about that i hope i don't have
omicron you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see you over at timcast.com and that mag
and that members only segment at 11 or
so p.m and again thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you